so last week we want to get an update
from Carly
Carlito with the tito's and she obliged
and sent one in and we haven't even
addressed that Chin's not here also chin
passed away oh okay corona damn chin why
he's wearing got a fight with some
murder wasp and won and won but he's
pretty [ __ ] up like Walter White if
you were a j'en he's in all black huh
is he there Chin's there now walking
around doing some drinking can he hear
us other is yeah what's up dudes
dad hey daddy chin going on guys what's
going on dude we're so sorry that this
happened we all look we want you to know
that we don't think you did it and
mm-hmm you know this is just a case of
mistaken identity man this is gonna pass
I don't think you killed those cats all
right yeah sorry about that yeah you're
a good guy man and we've already all
given statements that show our support
brother appreciate it man this is the
first time I've seen chin without a mask
yeah chanting no one's here I'm gonna
studio by myself ah so you take the mask
off I'll take the pants off mask off
what's that song mask off is it really
hot pursuit oh yeah yeah now Jim we have
this girl in the line here and you dated
her one point or you well you guys dated
yeah yeah but yeah she sent an update
after finding out some of the stuff do
you wanna hit play gin if you drink four
hundred dollars worth of sake
you dated y'all ready yeah hey guys
doing well I heard you wanted a little
update on my life since we last spoke
and
since we all found out that chin had a
girlfriend [ __ ] anyone date with me
which was very surprising huh me dick
but I don't want some reason Elfi chin
and I hope it works out for you a little
advice though
don't do that but she's right thank you
for teaching me that apparently guys can
be any age and have a girlfriend and
stove on dates with women oh she's not
other than that like it's been pretty
much the same everything is now working
from home or at home some getting on the
board and all you ready to get back into
the real world the sweater puppies are
girl I'm still dating and I'm still on
the market Theo oh I have to take a
break from Garmin's [ __ ] scars from
Johnny Depp and go on a date somebody
wants to pet that trying to rub the tip
on the mullet somebody's trying to
bounce around in the steam style don't
work like that hog call hey Carl's
trying to get that k so you know she has
to get through that mask oh yeah Chen
what about it then you tricked this girl
into going to a $400 just [ __ ] you sneak
away from your wife for a couple of
hours I'm a wife just my girlfriend but
what do you feel about her reaction I
feel like she came she was throwing a
little bit of ha but a shade a little
bit of shade I couldn't hear what she
said so what did you say like 40 year
old she said it's good to know that guys
at any age will lie and say they don't
have a girlfriend oh well I mean like
you guys already know it happened right
after we started this big no whatever if
I had to go through with it
so I apologized to her one more time
yeah yeah no no hard feelings right chin
no no no no I feel like the hates on her
side a little bit it could be this whole
corona thing too you know like she's
just taken out on Asians it's a popular
thing to do
yeah that's true this is definitely are
you feeling a lot of heat right now Jim
being Asian and you guys being
responsible for a little bit of the
worlds demise kind of overall you know
as I told Brennan to Brian to you that
when I went to the market to the store
people will literally walk away from me
and not walk away from other people that
don't look like me yeah they're upset
now I know what that's like
apparently they're starting to call you
guys yeah they look kind of like come on
that shirt I think you're all right
Chappelle wear that shirt looks like
Huey Lewis dude nothing else I like
white people have a Tommy Bahama shirt
yeah they're gonna you're gonna get
especially the night edition girl
governor's shirts don't yeah that
[ __ ] great hitter the [ __ ] she did
row that shirt that's just some downtown
LA homeboys that's your give up with a
box of wheat then it's the widest a
[ __ ] fruit by the foot don't go back
to wearing black now you'll get a
bulldog you're dressed like Kobe
Bryant's honeymoon we could all you the
[ __ ] out on a skateboard right now
though for reals man with the Vans the
shirt dude oh my god how do you should
tell well she's stepping out of the box
yeah yeah that's true man you trying
something different well Jim what do you
what do you say - Carly kind of throwing
shade your way you what do you you know
honestly she has every right to be a
little bit a little bit no she's just
right to throw a little bit of shade
you're good honey Decker she wasn't
gonna grab me anyways right I was gold
for her she had a delicious two-hour was
it
Korean barbecue dinner
and so do oh please I see something else
why I thought you're gonna say listen we
had a a two-hour fun dinner
she has delicious tips going I thought
you were gonna talk about those milk
barns she's built in her front yard
there's our dairy silos here's what I'm
telling you chin inflate lows yeah if
you have a wife tell a woman first
that's all I'm saying
that's fair you know and that's fair
yeah I feel like a hot Karl times gone
by it's not Chin's fault you're single
and now she's shooting these [ __ ]
Tatas at Theo's way uh-huh they don't
work like that girls look I mean like a
nice girl I'll pay for the date if you
want yeah I'll pay for it and but we got
to be able to film it I'm gonna do it do
it do for the show I don't know if I'm
ready to be dating right now dude I just
bought this outfit I feel like you are
ready yeah I feel like that screams
let's date Johnny Depp give the night
off I'll pay for it now I am what about
us friends huh what about you just good
you eat some Korean barbecues friend I'm
not driving someone to meet a friend
dude what do you think it's [ __ ]
1800s right all right
I tried my best guys sorry team no look
I think it would be fun but I don't know
if I want to do it or not so great no
you're doing hot Karl the Dikembe
Mutombo
yeah Karl here's what he's saying where
does she live out again chin where'd you
leave her at I think she lives around
Newport Beach I remember Oh beautiful
some of the best maybe wants the kind of
the one if the virus dies down or
something oh well we're opening up on
Friday may be based on Friday well I
would have to see if I can do it or no
says a lot excuse no I'll have to see if
I can do it Chappelle let you borrow the
shirt yeah I will Brooke come on now
come on this will do you good
No
yeah I ain't doing nothing in that shirt
except playing hide-and-go-seek with
everybody and not telling them that I'm
doing it sure we don't know Lakers game
and the note Cabana but I wear some
Malibu rum if you like Malibu rum you
rock that shirt chappal know what the
[ __ ] you're doing bro drink I appreciate
the invite and if I if I want if I
decide to I'll hit you up is that I'm
not trying to be rude I don't know cuz
you can go through me help I'll figure
details there you go yeah blood Brendan
Brendan will be the cube root maitre d
the middle man whooping dude can you
believe we will be your dark web yeah
he'll be the dark web
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]